Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
June 20th, 2016 what's going on? How are you, how are you doing,
you cons. Um, do you notice? Sounds a little weird. Uh,
I am in a hotel in Baltimore, Baltimore,
Baltimore. Um,
I can't say that cause I've watched Scarface so many fucking times.
I can't watch, I can't say Baltimore without picture and fucking, you know Tony,
Mike is that fucking ac coming back on again?
How many fucking times I gotta hit off? Ah, Jesus fucking
Christ. It's a fucking button on here. It literally just says off.
Off We go off. Shut off. Please shut off.
Thank you. Fuck Sakes. I'm sorry. Um, anyway,
so believe it or not,
I'm doing this because I'm flying back to La as you're listening to this and I'm
so sad to say, I haven't watched the fucking NBA finals yet,
but I do promise you if Cleveland wins, then I will do something. Ah,
I gotta do something specialist something. Um, cause who's kid? No,
the warrior's already won it, right? If they repeat, fuck, sorry.
I held it too closely. If they repeat, then it's going to be like, all right,
can they three pizza next year?
I feel like is their big thing so that they can go down with all the teams that
have won three in a row. So this year is sorta like, you know, you know,
it's not as exciting. I'm sure warrior fans who I don't give a fuck.
I'd love to see Lebron do it. You know,
after everybody gave him shit for the way he left,
which they should have because like I said, he gave everybody fucking, you know,
sports blue balls. Like maybe I'll go here, maybe I'll go there.
Who wants to buy me a drink? Yeah,
he was being very cunty and then he went to fucking Miami. Jesus Christ.
What the fuck happened to her? I could have the TV not on, in the background.
Okay,
good Lord. Getting old is the worst. I just saw some woman,
she had her fucking head.
Do you ever see like when a dog gets confused and cocks her head,
like her head was just like that? Um, what is that called? What does that from,
how do you avoid that?
Is it fucking alternate neca exercises you can do on the other side of your
fucking head so that doesn't happen to you. It's so fucking weird. Why?
Why can't you just like, you know,
why can't death just be like the old right there, Fred, you don't any,
why does it have to be just like this slow fucking dissension into like,
God knows what? The older I get, the more frightening that is.
When you're younger, you just like Jesus,
that old fuck what happened to them and me, I'm looking at it now going like,
you know, in the next 20 fucking years, you know,
I've got to start eating better. Jesus Christ.
I'm off the rails and by fucking date,
does anything make you feel fatter than Eaton room service in your bed,
in a fucking hole, just eaten in yet in a bed in general,
nothing makes you feel fatter than eaten in bed. You know,
just fucking sitting there getting crumbs in your sheets and shit and you're
trying to scrape it off onto the floor. You just feel like a fucking animal.
You like lay it on you. I was like literally on my side, I'm in Maryland,
so I got some sort of crab cake sandwich.
Of course it sucked because I got it at the hotel instead of the spot to get it
at right, and I'm on my fucking side and I'm eating the fries.
I'm literally sitting there like that fucking lifeguard.
You know when he got shit faced and he was eating the burger and everybody
laughed at and Hasselhoff,
everybody was laughing at him like it was fucking nuts. To me. It's like like,
dude, but you never did that. You never just been laying on your foot floor,
hammered eating a fucking, you should try it.
Sometimes the food is delicious. It takes it to a whole other level. Yes.
So fucking psyched and so appreciative of the Goddamn food. You know?
If he wants to know, I advocate everybody doing that this week.
Get fucking hammered order burger, lay on your floor.
Just start talking shit in honor of father's Day while your daughter films you.
And I think that's, I think that's the way to go. Um,
people already texted me. You watched the game anyway, tonight.
Now I'm fucking working. Actually somebody tweeted at me going, what the,
what's with your agent? Why the hell would you agent book a show?
You know, when this game seven of the NBA finals, it's like, hey,
stupid.
Like we booked it after game six things been on the books for months.
We had no fucking idea. I didn't know. So, um,
anyways, uh, I really want to see, I love the warriors man, by the way.
You know, I have no beef with those guys, but it's just as a sports fan,
when I don't have a dog in the fight,
it would just be great to see the Bron after all this shitty got and all those
sad,
sad Cleveland fans burned his Jersey standing there and they're fucking cargo
shorts, right? Burden the Jersey.
What people filled it so fucking stupid. That is so stupid.
And I'm not singling out Cleveland Cavalier fans,
but when people just take sports to that level,
like when Lane Kiffin left fucking Tennessee and there was that one guy going,
let me tell you something.
He fucking piece of Shit Lane Kiffin Egan fucking leave here.
You're going to leave here like Tana sees it.
We ain't no stepping stone to USC. We're booking,
we're fucking destination skills without think book and lane book keep it and I
don't know what he had.
He had some lane Kiffin something or like a program and he fucking peed on it.
A grown man filmed themselves paying on that program. It's like, dude,
someday you're going to have kids. The fuck is wrong with you.
Well I don't give a fuck fuck and kids, I have them right there.
They are little dicks out you right with me.
I don't take it to that fucking level or whatever.
So I always thought it was stupid.
You know this is something like really like medieval about like it's looks like
you're at a burning or something when you sit in there burning a jersey,
you know what I mean? It's like,
is Jesus going to come down the street with his cross neck?
Next thing is start yelling. Crucify him. It's, you know,
at the end of the fucking day, who you know, who gives a shit?
If you went the fucking options. Cleveland fans, all right?
Of Stain and miserable downtown Cleveland with all those miserable fucking fans
are going to Miami beach with some of the hottest fucking ass that is ever been
fucking grace the earth, you know,
beautiful fucking weather, right? You buy a hurricane proof house.
I don't know what the fuck that looks like,
but God knows if anybody had the money, it'd be a fucking professional athlete,
you know? Of course you would go down there. You want a couple, two,
three. When he went three down there. Alright, four or five. Yes. Six. Yeah.
Six finals in a row and he come back to Cleveland. All right,
you fucking snowed. Cons and we go and I'm going to say,
I'm going to go big air on this one right now. I say,
if Lebron, if Lebron fucking
leads the Cleveland Cavaliers to the championship tonight,
tonight, tonight gave seven, seven, seven, seven years, um,
in my mind he passes Colby Bryan. All right, I'm just pausing right now. Oh,
what the fuck everybody's going to say all that shit. I just feel like a,
okay,
the level of leadership that he would have to show
in order to do that. You know what I mean?
Compared to the teams that Coby played on where he had all this fucking help.
You know what I mean?
Cause I feel like Lebron's already done the Cobi Championship where you piled on
with Shaq and all that fucking shit.
He went down there with Dwayne Wade and all those guys,
but to go to the middle of fucking nowhere as far as sports goes and lead a
fucking sad sack.
Fucking city set sac city auto out of the fucking,
they're cursed lack of championships is,
is a way bigger accomplishment than any than any of Co-pi's five that he had.
You know, my big beef with Tim is he,
if Phil Jackson wasn't the coach and he didn't have major free agents signings
there, they immediately became a 500 team with Colby scoring 40 points a night.
You know, just being like, well, I got my stats. You guys suck.
And then he just would walk off the court. I Dunno.
I would in my sports mind,
my unathletic comedic sports mind, I put that with like,
just watching like the Pistons walking off the court when the fucking bulls
finally beat him. Those shadows. Just something fucking wrong about that.
Walking off the fucking court. What do you fucking share? Um,
um, did she ever walk off the court?
Did she walk off a battleship ever when they,
she didn't think the sound was right. I have no fucking idea. Anyways,
I'm plowing ahead here. Um, I had an amazing fucking time. I did, uh, Newark,
New Jersey, um, performance at Santa, whatever the hell they called.
It had some great shows.
And then last night I played this some fucking place in, um,
I don't know why. I don't know the names on this run. Um, hang on a second.
Typing in the password. One fucking word letter at a time.
I played this place last night and it was the same venue where Mike Tyson
knocked out fucking, uh, Michael Spinks. Now granted,
you know, the way they sat at when he had zonked,
I sold the same amount of tickets, believe me. Um,
they can see it in all these different ways.
So they sat at more for comedy show, but when he fucking did it,
it was like right now at turtle goddy fought there.
All these amazing boxing matches, uh, had had been there.
And if you went in there, man, I literally felt like I was in citizen Kane.
I got to get you guys the name of this fucking place.
One of the more amazing places I've ever gotten to walk into.
I had this old fucking, um,
this old Oregon there and shit as it can still going to be on my website or know
for fuck sakes. Bill Bell Burger
just got built bud fucking dope. Phoenix city. Let's see. Let's see.
Let's see. Something, something ballroom coming and fence.
You know, you fucking how fucking it just disappears. It's unbelievable.
You're kicked in the balls that fucking lives forever on the Internet.
Fucking one. God Damn. Day later, I can't find it. Whatever.
Lannick I'll tell you,
if you ever want to make a zillion dollars in Atlantic city,
open up a tattoo removal, fuck a tattoo removal store,
whatever you call it, service Jesus Christ. I have,
those were some of the worst fucking tattoos I've ever seen in my life.
What the fuck is the name of the venue? You can't,
this is what I do and I can't figure it out.
Just start landing city boardwalk hall and I'm actually,
you know, my, my back has been way better, but just riding in a car,
I don't know what it is. It just fucks with my leg. I get this,
the nerve starts acting up again, but I'm like 85% of the way back.
I'm really psyched. So, um,
I didn't want to deal with driving that two hour thing down the turnpike. So,
uh, I actually for once blew a little bit of cash and,
uh,
I took a helicopter ride down from the fucking west side of Manhattan Down to
Atlantic City was the shit. I flew in an a star, um,
got to sit up right next to the pilot.
I didn't get one of the seats in the back, which was cool.
I bought a ticket and piled on this thing.
Some other people going down there and I'm so fucking Shit,
man. He came out like, I was always terrified of being like, Oh man,
I don't know if I would want to fly. I still wouldn't,
I would never fly around Manhattan without an instructor because it's just so
much fucking traffic.
But you just go out over the Hudson and just like you're driving down the
street, you just get on the right side.
I couldn't look over and sees gauges to see what altitude we were flying at.
We went right down the Hudson River and I'm by the Freedom Tower and all that
stuff. And then we got to the other side. On the other side.
We've got the south side and this, um,
you know the statue of Liberty's right there, Ellis island.
And then we went right over the Verrazano Bridge and there's no way to fucking
go over that thing and not think good fucking Saturday night fever. You know,
when that fucking Guy Bobby, whatever his fucking name is,
tries to do the head stand. Look at me. I'm like, you guys right? Look at me.
They're like, Bobby, don't fucking do it.
Bobby said him and his, well he has to suit,
just go all the way down to the fucking bottom man.
It's fucking fucking unbelieve. I'm at that fucking scene.
Scared the shit on me when I was a kid, but now you know,
his fucking Afro and his fucking big collar, you know,
it's almost like if he went in head first he would have been fine or actually
maybe it would absorb too much water and he'd hit the bottom. I have no idea.
But anyways, we went over that, then we went over Red Bank, New Jersey,
made a right and went right down the coast. Went by Asbury Park.
So the fucking Jersey show me, it actually made me think like,
I can't believe I never went to either one of those places. Um,
but down to Atlantic City and then we, uh,
had a great time down there and tonight I'm in Baltimore,
so that's basically it. But a fucking underrated,
underrated being in Manhattan, blowing a little bit of cash,
piling onto a fucking helicopter with a few other fucking passengers getting the
last seat and fucking flying by that amazing skyline, man.
It was the shit. It was the shit. And I finally got to ride a,
a star and a, it was way less intimidating than I thought it was going to be.
I thought when I looked at the cockpit, all the gauges and everything branded,
they were analog. I don't like that digital shit. I fucking hate that stuff.
I don't trust it. I don't like it. I'm not a technology guy.
I like when everything looks like a fucking weird clock,
then I feel like I can read it. I don't, I don't like all that,
that type of shit. So, um, anyways,
how many minutes do I have to here?
I will do the advertise and I just don't know if it's coming yet. Um,
let's see if we got anything. Nothing. So anyways, as always,
as I've been trying to mention here so I can support, um, my fellow comics, um,
if you like this podcast or stuff like this or maybe you're sick of it and you'd
like to listen to another one. Uh, we have,
I feel the best collection of 'em of podcasts on that.
Have any other podcasts network at the all things comedy network.
We've got Bert Kreischer, we got a who else we got? We got,
uh, Philippe as far as what's up fool podcast.
We've got Aaron Foley's fucking sports without balls. We got Dean del Rey's let,
let there be Doug. Stan hope lose his murderers fucking row here.
Bunch of other fucking people on here. Um,
and it's all just high quality stuff. Eddie Pepitone, Tom Papa. Come on man.
What else? She going to get podcasts like this, um,
Thomson Gore and your mom's house. We got all kinds of stuff there. So, uh, um,
let me click on a few of these here so I can give some shout outs.
Irish affairs, skeptic tank. Um, it's a great website and a,
we just got some investors on it, which is great.
So we're going to start having some more original content,
which is why I'm trying to drive some traffic there and be a good fucking team
player. Okay.
So after I do my show here tonight and beautiful fucking Baltimore,
Baltimore, um, I'm flying, this is my fucking day.
I'm flying out to la.
I go right into the writers room and after that I'm doing a a,
I'm doing a benefit that's really important to me. Um, great friend of mine,
Bobby Slayton,
unfortunately his wife passed away a few months ago and we're doing a,
a benefit and memory of her at the Saban Theater in uh,
Beverly Hills and uh, the fucking lineups. Ridiculous.
Arsenio Hall is hosting and there's a few other up and coming comics you
might've heard of like, I dunno, Ray Romano, Dana Carvey, Jon Lovitz,
Brian Regan, Bob Saget,
and I'll be a fucking pulling up the rear. They have a
low man on the totem pole and that show would definitely be me. Um,
I'm a huge fan of all of those guys,
so I can't believe I'm going to get to work with them. Um,
unfortunately it's not the greatest reasons why we're doing it, but, um,
we love Bobby and um, it's a great benefit. There are a few tickets left.
It's going to be a crazy show and I have a feeling all those guys are going to
be fucking with each other cause they known each other for so long and uh,
I want to be like beyond a fan boy that night. And then, uh,
then after that I go home and then I go right on a fucking plane.
I have to go back to New York because a,
I've got to work with some actors to do some voiceovers.
We're up to episode eight. Everybody know recording episode seven. Huh?
Dodd days is summer. We'll coming around but coming around so fucking site,
we're a up to episode seven. We're going to do the table riff episode,
April accord, the table a the fucking episode.
Um,
yeah, next week. Hey, you know, I just realized, you know, it'd be cool if this,
if one of you guys out there wanted to come to a table read,
I gotta figure out how to do a,
a some sort of contest or something maybe bringing in for episode 10,
whenever we record that. Uh,
I don't know why the fuck I never thought to do that. You know, it's funny,
I don't even invite my wife to him. I'm so busy like pouring over the script,
making sure, you know, I don't fuck up the jokes at the table read, but, um,
you know what, I'm going to figure out how to do that and I'm,
I'm promising you right now, by next Thursday. Yeah. Thursday's podcasts.
We'll have something set up for that. I think that'd be a really cool,
if you're into the show, if you're not into the show,
then you'd probably be like, wait, bill,
maybe I just want to go get a fucking cheese stick or some shit. Cheese. Steak.
Sorry. Anyways, let me, uh,
what else did I want to talk about here?
This is usually where I do the fucking advertising. I guess I can't this week.
Um, oh, formula one racing. Oh,
the European Grand Prix over there. Um,
I actually didn't get a chance to watch that cause I stayed out too late,
but I did tape it. But spoiler alert, spoiler alert,
a Nico Rosberg fucking Nico,
Nico Rosberg he won his fifth fucking race, right? One, two, three, four, five.
He's won five of them. He's the points leader.
He's said he's with the German team and he's uh,
just funny. Ross Park, you know what I mean?
It's about time they fucking made up for it. Had a Jewish guy drive for them,
you know, um, I don't even know if he's Jewish or anything, but uh,
he also drives from Mercedes, so I always root for Germany and Mercedes because,
uh, I've never done a background check,
but I think I'm mostly German just based on, uh, what my parents have told me.
Um, but oh my God, I saw the pictures of it too,
just driving through this beautiful fucking city.
I don't know where the fuck I been for so goddamn long when it comes to Formula
One. Now, of course me because I'm a psycho. Somebody told me about the fucking,
you know, the basically the former formula one of, of motorcycle racing. Um,
I don't know why I'm not watching that.
I sit there and I flip out where I love all these fucking crazy contact sports.
Right? You know, I like rugby, Australian rules,
football and this fucking Mad Max shit that people been showing me lately where
it's sort of rugby sort of soccer and after somebody scores you can punch them
in the face. I don't know what the fuck that is. It's like football,
soccer, rugby and bullying all at the same fucking time, man.
It's just, I don't know about that sports. You don't,
the only thing that was missing was just to have a couple of bulls run in there
and just start fucking trampling people. Um,
okay.
But anyways, uh, let me shut this fucking TV off.
This is really fucking with my brain here. Um,
I don't know why if I liked all that type of shit.
Why watching somebody ride a motorcycle 200 fucking miles an hour.
Um, it's absolutely incredible.
It is amazing to me is these guys are so good that when they go down,
they don't die somehow. You think they, I mean that same people don't die,
but you'd think they would die every fucking time. You know what I mean?
The fact that you can wear a fucking suit
that is so God damn strong human go 200 miles an hour and you could fall off
your fucking bike and it just does.
Like what should happen there is like after fucking two seconds of skidding on
the asphalt at 200 miles an hour immediately you should just see the guy's ass.
His Berra has, should be there.
And then you just see it looks like steak and then it would look like bones and
then that would just be it and the guy would be dead.
You would think that that would happen every time.
And these fucking guys just slide in these goddamn suits and were incredible.
Not saying people don't die. But um, I think, um,
I think this is sort of my next thing man. Cause like you, what's funny,
this time of year when hockey ends and basketball ends,
everybody is a football fan. You know,
Pixie the hockey or hoop for the most part. All right.
Very few go hockey and then wait and go baseball.
I only know a couple of guys like that.
So people go hockey or fucking hoop and um,
people who watch hockey don't watch who people watch hoop,
don't fucking watch hockey. They have nothing in common with each other.
And the only thing that they have in common with each other other than their
love of football is the sheer fucking panic of the day after the game seven or
your final or your finals when that's over and you're like, holy fuck,
what am I going to do now for the next two and a half fucking months is I wait
for the NFL regular season to start.
And I'm not shitting on baseball because I love baseball. I just,
the the fucking dog days of summer, I can't stand like,
you know who the fuck wants to go to the ballpark.
It's like fucking a hundred degrees out. You know who does die hearts?
I guess I'm not a die hard baseball fan, but I love it. I love it in October,
so I needed a sport and Formula One dude,
I'm telling you like the race today was,
it was only like something like 50 something laps.
You can really just sit down and they bang it out in a couple of hours.
You know, you get to learn about other fucking cities, you know,
half of them they go to like, oh shit, I'd like to go there,
get all those people hanging out, calling it right now.
At some point I'm going to hit a fucking country when they have a formula one
race, there's actually one here. It says,
the United States says United States Grand Prix for the life of me,
I think it's an Austin, Texas,
which is really disappointing to me that that's where they're going to fucking
have it. You know what I mean? Why the fuck is it in Austin, Texas?
They should have that thing in like Chicago,
Chicago should have a Formula One fucking race.
That's a cool ass fucking city, you know,
fucking zip and over the rivers at one point, only one car could make it.
They'd probably kill each other. Um,
I don't even know what the track looks like in Austin, but, um,
all I know is Austin is a great city. Once you're in it,
trying to get to it with that fucking traffic is an absolute goddamn nightmare.
So, um, anyways, I guess this is a place here where I would actually pause,
right? And I would do some sort of advertising. Um,
I'm just gonna say this so I can edit it in later.
We're going to pause here right now. The little bit of that advertising,
when the fuck is my reads, come on, give me the reads, give me the reads.
Ah, you can't. All right. But you know what?
It doesn't matter you guys because this is not going to be in real time for
yourself. Oh my God.
Does this podcast suck as bad as it sounds in my fucking head right now. Um,
you know, I was going to say about Baltimore. Every time I go to the Baltimore,
Baltimore, the Baltimore, I always think about the wire and I was going to go,
I remember the wire and then I was going to go boom, booboo, booboo,
which is for law and order. I can't even remember how the fucking song went.
I just remember the song in the end, the guy was screaming up.
But as you can tell,
I'm kind of losing my fucking voice with the voiceover shit and screaming about
my deck here and stage. Um, but you know,
what I'm psyched about is my fucking act is coming together and I'm getting
ready to do another special, I think I'm going to do it in October,
and all I gotta do is just get through these last three fucking episodes. Okay.
Give 100% on that shit, and then that's it. Then all of a sudden,
it's all Billy fucking flank steak.
Remember when I said I wasn't going to drink? You know,
I fucked up on Thursday, Friday and Saturday. Okay.
But I was great Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, and Sunday. Right?
So when I get back, I'm going back to not drinking. I gotta,
I gotta get back off this, but I just, I don't know what happened. You know,
I fucking, uh, I don't happen, you know? And you know what happened?
I went on the fucking road. That's what happened.
I went to New York and I met up with some fucking friends and like, Hey,
let's go to this fucking bar. And then, you know,
it's like one of these wine bars, you know,
so you don't feel like you're drinking. So I showed up, you know,
another buddy of mine that's fucking comic. I'm not going to say,
I don't wanna name any names, but this guy's fucking hilarious.
And he comes in and it was hilarious. He called them out.
He just goes like, cause he showed up and uh, I know what you're saying,
but why did you go to a wine bar?
Because there were ladies there and that's what they fucking picked, right?
So we're like, all right, I'm gonna fucking go there.
So he shows up and I immediately got, dude,
it's a wine bar. I don't, cause he wanted a beer and a shot and I,
his face fucking dropped in verse. He called out,
he goes to the level of fucking disappointment on your face.
And then we find out that they had beer and they did have a shot,
but it was this, you know, this foofy place. So the dude goes, uh, they go,
can I get some drink? He goes, yeah, can I just get a a bud light?
And the guy's like, ah, yeah, no, we don't, we don't have bud light. Uh,
we have, we have a Papa Bubba, bull bull, whatever the fuck it is,
some Italian beer. And he goes, guys like, Oh, what?
He's like a Bababababa Bowl? And he just goes, yeah, is, is that a beer?
And the guy goes, yeah. And he goes, all right, I'll have one of those.
And I don't know what happened.
Then we started doing Tequila shots and the whole fucking thing went off the
rails. And I'm a fat fuck. And I all like myself right now there.
I said it a fucking in a hotel. Roman Baltimore eaten French fries in bed.
Huh? Like some fucking,
I dunno if somebody whose dreams didn't come true,
that's who eats French fries in bed or maybe people who fucking everything
worked out for them and they're just so fucking bored. They, you know,
like Marlon Brando, whatever the fuck his issue was. Oh,
I've won every award that exists. Bring me a fucking elk.
Said he just sat in bed just non on the fucking amblers for like 10 years and
all of a sudden, you know, he's ready to do the fucking,
what is it? What the fuck? Gorilla Monsu movie. I have biopic. I have no,
I don't know how those things work. I don't pretend to fucking know. Um,
so anyways, we're going to pause here for a little bit of advertising.
Bill flooring, come back with a Monday morning podcast.
Okay. And we're back. Um,
so I figured I'll take me a good fucking three minutes to read those cuts.
Maybe five minutes or whatever that means they can get to the, I can get to the,
uh, the questions right now. Can I, I think I can't,
don't get too close to Mike. Bill Second. You fucking ask. Exhale.
It all goes off the fucking rails. Um, alright.
Here we go. All right, advice first. You know,
some kind of fucking Ireland,
some cutting island gave me shit about the ticket prices.
I think that's a little bit too much. I think you funny. It's like, Hey Douche,
how about the fact I'm flying from the other side of the fucking world?
Almost onto your fucking doorstep. That's not enough for you.
Who's going to pay for all that fuel? Um, all right, here we go. Advice for,
for a daft Scotsman. Hey there, you're redheaded content.
Ah, I cannot fucking wait to go back to Scotland,
Ireland and all these fucking places,
these miserable cons to some of the funniest people you ever going to meet.
Alright, he says, I'm 26 year old guy from near Glasgow, Scotland.
Um, for quite a while I was in a bit of a Rut,
but eventually I managed to pick myself out of it and decided to do something
that I've always wanted to do.
I took a big step and decided to buy a ticket to a festival in Chicago. I said,
shit, I love Chicago. Said,
I booked my flights and I'll be in the city for a week. That's tremendous.
So basically my question is as I'll be traveling alone and we'll be staying
alone,
how easy is it to just hang around and strike up conversations with complete
strangers in a different country?
Have you ever found difficulties in finding common ground in conversation with
people from different countries? Also,
any full pause I should avoid when talking to Americans so I can prevent getting
my cunt kicked in. All the best you fat shaming, Prick.
Um, all right. It's a lot of questions there. Um,
well the only time I ever traveled is when I, I'm doing stand up.
And then after the show there's always people that just saw you do a show.
So I've already broken the ice. But um, first things first,
why don't I tell you a couple of places to go to from my little fucking places
to go, thing that I have in my fucking phone that my wife used to make fun of.
She made fun of places to go and she was laughing and then, you know what?
We went to one of those fucking places and then all of a sudden, you know,
she's just, she has total faith in it. Now she tells me to hit it. All right,
here's what I would go. All right.
If you like a nice fucking a great fucking bar for music and that type of thing,
I'd go to the Liar's club. Um, if you like cigars is a place,
big cigar in pouring them, check that fucking place out.
And then as far as food and all that shit, I would just tweet about it because,
uh, I'm not a big fan of, of, of deep dish pizza, you know what I mean?
I just don't understand it.
I don't understand deep dish patient pizza the way I don't understand why white
coffee and tea have to be so fucking hot. You know what I mean?
I what? So it gets the fucking, the teabag all in the water maybe.
Is that what the fuck it is? I just don't understand.
But you have to wait like an hour before you can drink it without scalding your
fucking mouth. And when it comes to deep dish pizza, it's, it's just,
it's just too fucking much, you know,
and you can't just get a slice of it that they bring the fucking thing over.
It's, it's like, hey, you want some lasagna? Yeah,
but not a whole fucking tray, you know? Um,
but you should definitely try it.
If you get one that actually has a really good crust, it is pretty amazing.
But it's just like, I mean,
you can literally split one piece with somebody else. It's so fucking big. And,
uh, my wife said the funniest shit about it. She called it an abomination.
She goes, it's the ultimate expression of American gluttony. She goes,
go to Italy, you won't see anything, anything over there like it.
And it's true. We went to Italy, you know, they have like,
we have all our American versions of their dishes, you know what I mean?
But there's no deep dip. The deep dish pizza in Italy,
at least not in any place we went to in. That's the only place I've been to.
But you don't see it a, that's what she said. And she goes, you know why?
Because it's an abomination. Um, so anyways, uh,
as far as I found in that, that Liars Club, uh,
people were fucking cool as hell. If you're into the music and shit,
it's a good time. But Dude,
you're going to be coming over with your fucking accent.
I wouldn't go to the fucking, you know, I, you know,
depends on what you're into. I would go to a, uh,
a place where it's going to be a bunch of beautiful women.
That's what I would do. And then you go over there and you just fucking just,
just start talking and I think you'll be in the fucking game and they'll be,
who'd you come over here with? I came over by myself.
I want to always wanted to come to Chicago. And just literally,
you know how HR watch, he goes, what are you fucking Berge do?
Whatever the flower of the fuck you guys talk. Right?
Who the fuck you fuck do over here for fun?
You're scared wherein could write whatever the fuck you going to say and they're
going to love it. They're going to love it. Even if you ask him, Hey,
for fucking Shag, any however the fuck you say fucking in your country,
it's going to seem so cool to them. It's so different.
And then also they're going to be more adventurous because you know, you're,
the story's leaving with you when you go back, when you fly back to Scotland.
Um, how can you avoid getting your head kicked in? Um,
don't do what everybody else from other countries do is you come here and you
criticize the United States and talk about how dumb we are,
how fat we are, how awful the foreign policy is, how uh,
our football players are pussies cause they wear pads.
Why do you call it football? All of that dumb shit. You know what I mean?
It's so fucking obnoxious. You know?
You know why it's obnoxious because they have those kinds of people always come
here and they act like these. They're these worldly traveled people, you know,
oh I come from here and I come from there and we can do this and we can do that.
And it's just like, well, in all of that fucking travel,
you never learned to be on your best behavior when he'd come to somebody's
country and you don't come in and insulted.
So you make your whole country look like a bunch of fucking snobby cunts.
You never learned that one. I am always,
I'm on my best fucking behavior when I go to a different country.
I'm not saying I'll go out and get fucking hammered,
but like I don't go there and shit on it, you know?
Yeah. Some of these places I go to, I'm fucking talking to people.
I know this place is nice. They always like, why the fuck did you come here?
Well, I was like, I was in Oslo, Norway. I said, you know,
you guys will thanks a lot. You guys were great.
I'll definitely be back if somebody yelled out. Why?
It just struggles. Like why? What do you mean? Why? Why the fuck wouldn't I,
it's fucking beautiful. I don't know. Anyway, so I would avoid doing that.
Um, and then just everything else is common sense. You know, somebody's,
you know, looking like a psycho. Just fucking leave him alone.
But I don't know, Dude. I, I mean I judge a lot of Scotland on that movie.
Trainspotting or I just feel like it,
I don't go into any bars where there's an upper deck to it cause I just feel
like there's going to be that guy up there that's going to finish his fucking
pint and just throw the glass over his head, cut open some woman's face.
Like I just, you know, if it's even remotely like that over there,
I think you're going to be fine in Chicago. Um,
I would definitely try to go to a cubs game. Uh, no offense to white sox fans,
but you guys all know that you fucking stadium stinks. You know, it stinks.
It's the only time I ever saw a stadium,
a new stadium built and they admitted so quickly like, wow,
we really fucked this up. Let's try it. And like, it was like a batch nose job.
You know what I mean? Like your stadium is the fucking stadium version of like,
you know, when some Hollywood chick or somebody,
they get too much work done on their face and people, oh my God, what happened?
That's what you did with that stadium. They're like,
oh well let's wait til it settles. Let's see what happens. You know,
so they go, but dude, you picked a great fucking city to go to.
Chicago is the shit. And then you picked a great time of the year to go there.
Um, I will tell the traffic is fucking horrific, so just get ready for that.
But once you're in it, it's fucking phenomenal. Um, all right.
What did we go here? All right. Uh, dear Billy,
stretchy pants on your podcast sometime back,
you were talking about someone getting with someone else and one of the people
gaining a bunch of weight. Oh yeah. When you start dating somebody,
how it's not fair to the other person for you to then put on a bunch of fucking
weight. Um, unless you're a woman, you having a baby that's obviously, you know,
I'm not a fucking animal here but I'm just saying, you know,
after you have the kid, you know, that's,
that's when you know after your wife has a kid, two things should happen.
This is what you do.
You get a little bassinet for the beautiful baby and then the second thing you
do is you get an elliptical for you wife.
But so she doesn't get mad at you.
What you do is you get our initials engraved on the side of it and plastic of
course. Totally kidding. All right. Um,
I was already a few weeks into whipping myself back into shape. Um,
okay.
Let me just start this over again cause I've even forgot what the fuck he's
talking about on your podcast sometimes back you sometime back you were talking
about someone getting with someone else and one of the people gaining a bunch of
weight. I was already a few weeks into whipping myself back into shape,
but this really helped me solidify my will. Well that's fucking great man.
That's great. I wish she can you help me? Cause I, you know,
sitting in a fucking writer's room is like,
I eat there like the way I eat on the road. I mean, I,
it's just fucking hard to try to eat healthy. It's just, you're just bored.
You're freaking out. You're locked in the fucking room and you're like, oh,
I'm gonna eat some fucking candy for no reason. I'm sitting there everyday like,
it's Halloween and I'm fucking seven years old. I got to stop. All right.
It made me think that I should really give my lady the respect of maintaining
something close to the body I had when she got on this train. Uh, she loves me.
She stayed with me in spite of the lumpy beanbag chair. I have become.
I am now. I'm 15 pounds down with a bunch more to go,
but I am back on my routine.
Four or five trips to the gym at five 30 in the morning. Dude,
you fucking killing it. That's great. And Calorie counting as well.
I know exactly what to do. It's just the time. Now my question is this,
how do you deal with it if your lady wants you to eat the same stuff she is or
wants to go to a shitty fried food restaurant. Anyways,
thanks man. Hope season two F of F is for family is coming along. Well it is.
Thank you sir. Can't wait to see it. And I loved your last show in Austin.
Hurry back and come during the football season.
We had a monster fucking recruiting class this year. Thanks your best. Oh,
that's great man. You could learn horn should be good.
So the legendary college program there. All right. Um, all right.
How do you deal with, I would just say I want just, that's easy as easy.
Just sit down with her and just say, hey listen,
you know when you got with me,
I was however years old and I w I weighed this much and I don't think it's fair
for me to have put on all this fucking weight, you know?
And they'd be looking like a lumpy beanbag chair like you said.
So I'm really trying to get myself back into shape. So I was wondering if,
you know, you know, if you want to eat something that's a little unhealthy,
is there any way we just can go to a place that has healthy options for me?
All right. Because a,
I don't want to look bad for you and I also don't want to die early.
So you're fucking, you know,
in your forties and 50s having to put lipstick on and get the fuck back out
there again and try to meet somebody who works down at Sears, you know?
And I don't, I don't want to do that to you.
I'd like to be here for the long haul, dude. There's no fucking way she,
she'll give you shit about that. That's a very easy thing to have happen,
you know? And then also I think, sorry, I'm looking at the timer.
I also think that she would be happy to hear that you weren't just doing this
for some vain reason yourself, that you were actually also doing it for her.
I think that that would be pretty cool. Now. Watch, now watch. She'll fucking
getting some big fucking fight, you know, or you think the thing I eat bad.
You say I'm fat. You know she blows her sales manager.
All right, read this. Okay. All right. I'm going to read this. Relax.
What's up dickhead? Let's go fucking Bruins. Can't wait for next season.
I just moved to wildly mediocre Los Angeles.
Uh, well yeah,
that's what you're going to feel like cause you just fucking moved there. Um,
but if you stay open minded,
which is really difficult for east coast people to do.
I did that the first time I came to la.
I went to La and I tried to do Boston New York Shit. And then when I couldn't,
I was like, dude, this place fucking sucks. It doesn't, it's fucking amazing.
Beautiful women.
Some of the best food you ever gonna have so much outdoor activity.
Just fucking embrace it. Stop trying to be the fucking Boston guy.
You're not on a reality show. All right. Take it down a few fucking notches.
Nobody gives a fuck in Los Angeles that you don't like it.
Everybody just thinks, well then go back to fucking Boston. Go back to Philly.
Wherever the fuck you're from. If it's so fucking great.
Why did you accept the job out here? All right. Sorry.
I'm just heading off at the past before you come. Another country. Shit.
Nine fucking la. And he said I worked for the UFC editing fight highlights.
Uh, thanks for keeping me entertained with your semi-literate bib babble.
Bullshit day after day. This is like a classic East Coast Guy.
He really likes me and likes what I, what I do,
but he just can't get himself to say it cause his dad never hugged him.
So I'm not taking any of this personally anyway.
My girlfriend is about to move here to meet me.
She had to stay behind when I move because she's a teacher and needed to finish
up the school year. Uh, we get along great.
I trust her and she treats me better than I deserve. However,
sometimes I can't take how ditzy she can be. Oh,
I'm starting to pull some threads here. She is successful and very book smart,
but sometimes lacks common sense.
I find feeling embarrassed when she says some stupid shit in front of my friends
or parents. It's kind of a hard thing to discuss with her though. You know,
what should, what the fuck should I do? Also,
I'm coming to your show with the same in theater this Monday.
I'm looking forward to it, so don't blow it. Well,
I appreciate you coming out to that. Like I said, it was, you know,
for a really good friend of mine and for a great cause. Uh,
so thank you for doing that. All right,
well here's the deal dude.
You either have to accept the fact that she can be a little ditsy or you have to
come to the realization that you're dating a fucking dope and you've got to get
rid of her. It's one of the other, um,
I mean, look, she doesn't sound like she's 100% that I've,
I've dated people like that that were a little, you know,
they were either locked in or just sort of floating.
It was really weird and they could say really like amazing,
like spot on shit.
And then two minutes later could just could say something like, oh my God,
what the fuck was that? Um,
but I have to tell you that's kind of a, that's kind of a big deal. They'll do,
you know, you can't think that the person you're dating is a dope, you know,
you get into that situation and uh, I dunno,
you start thinking about getting married, you start thinking about having kids.
You're like,
is my kid going to be half a dope or a full on dope is used as a kid going to
get all of that DNA from her over the fuck knows. Um,
all right. It's kind of a hard thing to discuss with her, you know,
what are you going to say to what, can you stop saying dumb shit? I mean this,
there's no way to do that, you know, I'm trying to think.
That's like my wife telling me that to, to work on my team. I mean,
I do work on my temper, but I mean, it's Kinda how I made up.
I mean, if somebody did see that fucking ditzy,
that'd be like my wife telling me, okay, can you be a little less pasty?
It's like I can, I can become red for a few days
as well. That's about the best I could do.
I don't know what else you want from me, but uh, you know, I think you, uh,
need to maybe move on. I'm not saying you need to move on it. Yeah.
You either accept this about her or IGA. You got to walk one of the Yoga.
Um, all right. Here's another one.
Jesus Christ can't come and I don't mean to the wedding.
Um, how's it going, Billy? Butterballs uh, if you're reading this on Monday,
it's fucking sick. June 20th
will is my 21st birthday. Oh, Jesus. I don't know what's going on here.
Great gift hearing you read this. Uh,
well you're not going to hear it until the fucking Monday anyways. All right.
I'm mailing, I'm mailing.
I'm emailing today though is I was with this girl last summer,
some good sex, no big deal,
but we didn't have anything going on during the year when we were at college.
Well, we're back at it this summer, but the thing is I can't come.
I mean I'm doing good. Pretty good. A PPM pumps per,
but I just can't finish now. I know you're not a doctor,
so not going to ask you why, but how should I go about this?
I think she's getting self conscious, but she's a hard eight and I'm a soft six.
She's hot. It's not her fault.
Daddy can finish Dedi can't finish when the pressure's on.
How should I be playing this? I can only laugh it off for so long.
I'll try not jerking off to maybe that'll help. Any advice?
Thanks for the read, man.
I'll feel I'll be able to come check you out when you come back. East Coast.
Maybe Baltimore on Sunday. Go socks. Go Fuck Yourself. Uh, yeah.
I don't rub one out. If you're watching too much porn, maybe that's a problem.
Or maybe you know, you don't want to be in a relationship with her.
And that's the weird way your body's reacting, like you're wasting time. Um,
so we're not going to fucking, I don't know,
there's a bazillion psychological reasons, but yeah, I, yeah,
just don't rub one out for awhile. You know, this is another thing too.
Women have fucking, they're very forgiving people. If I would,
I wouldn't laugh it off. I would talk to you about it and just say, listen,
obviously this is happening. It's bothering me. Um,
I'm feeling pressure about it and I'm also feeling like in a roundabout,
I just don't want you to be taking my issue on like, is something you are doing?
You're not doing anything wrong. There's something going on with me.
And then she'll be like, well, maybe you should go talk to somebody about it.
And because you're a fucking red sox fan,
I'm assuming you're from the Boston area, you don't want to go to therapy.
And even if you do go to therapy,
it's not going to help because you probably have enough Irish blood in you.
And they always said,
who is that fucking psychologist that said the Irish are like immune to therapy.
Um, I don't know if you liked this girl,
I would definitely talk to her about it. But, uh,
there's no reason to put any pressure on yourself. You know what I mean?
Just don't rub one out. Don't watch any porn. Just a, you know,
I don't know. Just let it back up.
I don't fucking know. I'm not a doctor. Jesus Christ. Jesus Christ started.
Here we go. Here we go. Wind it down. Wind it down. All right, heroin. Um,
I have no family, no friends. I work in support myself. I have no kids,
no relationship. I actually enjoy freedom and being alone to an extent.
I'm in my twenties.
I had a lot of sex relationships and ended up getting a herpes. Slash. HPV.
I would basically rather just not tell people and not have relationships than to
have, than to have to at 35 years old. Uh,
didn't have to at 35 years old deal with having to explain slash tell this to
women. I really like heroin. A what the fuck? Jesus Christ buddy. What are you,
what are we doing? Here it is. This doesn't sound real. I really like heroin.
I go to work, come home and use heroin on a daily basis. I still pay my bills.
I still work,
but I have traded the pleasure of sex slash having a family slash relationships
for that, of watching TV shows slash movies while high on heroin,
falling asleep, then going to work the next day. Should I change this?
Okay.
Is this re I, I'll try it. You know what, I'll, I'll treat it as real. Um,
should I listen to society, stop using,
go out there and find women and tell them about my situation and hope they do
not reject me and get clean or if I am happy,
is it okay for me to just accept the women part of my life is over,
eat whatever I want,
use whatever drug I want and fill the time I have left on this planet.
Watching shows, movies, playing games,
and resigning myself to the fact that I will be alone. Love the podcast.
Heroin gets a bad rap. It may sound crazy,
but people can use opiates and still be responsible. I know many people who do,
it's like alcohol. Both can be physically. This is really fascinating.
Um, uh, or maybe it's a big lie. I Dunno. It's alcohol. Uh,
it's like alcohol. Both can be physically addictive.
Alcohol can actually kill you with withdrawals.
Why heroin cannot.
And the deaths you hear about heroin are from idiots overdosing.
Um, if we, well, what if you get a bad batch? Isn't that something? You know,
it's too fucking strong. Um, I dunno. I don't pretend to know. All right.
If we reported all the deaths from alcohol involved incidents, they're easily,
well, they do report all of them. As far as I know.
It's like they're trying to hide them. Um,
they are easily 100 times more than heroin related deaths,
but in our society right now,
opiates are not acceptable because too many white middle class parents are
finding their idiot kids using them without understanding tolerance slash
okay.
Ah, proper dosing anyways, love the podcast.
I'm not leaving any contact info, so I have no way to know if you read this,
just thought it might be an interesting subject for your show.
It is interesting. Um, yeah, dude,
I don't pretend to know anything about opiates. All I do know is that the, um,
I know alcohol can ruin your life,
but I don't think it's nearly as addicting as heroin.
I've heard that people can fucking,
okay.
I don't know, but I think, I think if what you're saying is true,
I think you are a rare person that can handle that. I have no idea. Ah, fuck.
Now I've got to look some shit up.
The last thing I wanted to do and I got to get going here.
I got my fucking show here and a half hour. Um, oh,
the live reads are here. The live reads are here.
I guess I'll read them here then. Let me just see something. Um,
let me just look up. What do I look up
productive while on heroin,
heroin and employment. Independent drug morrow. Let's see.
Productivity and heroin addiction. What is this?
How heroin addicts in Vietnam. What is this
productivity and heroin addiction?
How living in a cave turned me into a blogger.
Okay,
I failed my new year's resolution. I wish I could do better.
I just don't have enough willpower. Have you ever set a goal you didn't achieve,
ever tried a new year's resolution that didn't stick?
What separates the 0.5% from the 99 and a half percent? What makes someone,
some people succeed in building new sustainable habits,
but almost everyone else fails.
Okay.
I'm living in a cave term. Where the fuck's the heroin shit.
How heroin addicts in Vietnam and your productivity habits are the same.
What everyone knows the horrible effects of heroin addiction.
Once someone starts taking herring, it's almost impossible to quit.
And those who form a recurring habit will likely never quit.
So why didn't heroin using Vietnam vets relapsed when they returned to the USA.
A study from the Washington School Medical School of Medicine,
very few heroin use in Vietnam, uh, veteran relapses.
Uh,
what very few heroin using veteran relapsed or relapsed when they returned the
USA.
And those who did were more likely to have been illicit drug users before ever
arriving in Vietnam. These vets weren't addicted to the chemicals and heroin.
They were addicted to the experience of how,
or an in a specific situational context. In the same vein,
you think you are in control of what you do. You think that when you fail,
it's a failure of your willpower,
but the fact is you don't even realize the influence of the environment has on
you. Did you know that obesity spreads through a network of friends?
Happiness also spreads throughout a social network.
You situation determines should choices as much as or more than your own
personal choices. When willpower.
Okay,
so how can I use this to improve my habit? Oh, it's Jesus Christ.
Don't join a Wally ball league. I don't even know what the fuck that was.
All right, let me, let me look up. Ah,
let me just read these fucking things here. Um, you know what?
I might read up on that. I probably won't. I'll try to,
I would never tell people to fucking, you know, age, just heroin. You know,
that seems a little crazy to me. Um, and people always come in and alcohol.
It's like the fucking pot smokers always doing that shit. Well,
the alcohol actually, man, there's no medicinal purposes to fucking, I get it.
I get it. But you know, you guys are also,
you know your pie in the sky fucking thing with weed. Like it's like this.
They keep, can't get addicted to weed is another fucking thing. Jesus Christ.
Okay. Yeah. You just really like it. That's all you know. All right.
You're unique. Oh, this is helix. Helux you're unique.
You don't walk like everyone else.
Talk like everyone else asleep like everyone else.
So why is your mattress one size fits all?
Because it truly customized mattress will cost you five to 10,000 bucks until
now. Go to helocs helix, sleep.com.
Answer a few simple questions then that run a three d bio, chem,
bio something or other model of your body
through the proprietary algorithms they develop with the help of the world's
leading aerodynamics and violence learning experts. The result,
the most comfortable mattress you've ever slept on looks customers report at 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality and for couples,
they customize each side of the mattress. Your mattress arrives.
I just pictured somebody have in one like the husband,
so he could bang a woman while his wife's sleeping and she would know, you know,
rather than than doing the red wine test.
But one guy jumps up and down while the red wine just sits there. Um, you know,
what about mattresses for those people?
Helix customers report a 30% improvement in overall sleep quality.
And for cuffs cuff couples, they customize each side of the mattress.
Your mattress arrives at your door in about a week and shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes are all talking about helix
sleep. You have 100 nights to try it out. And if you don't love it,
they pick it up for free and give you 100% refund. No questions asked.
Gross. What do they do with that mattress? Go to helix,
sleep.com/burn and get a $50 $50 off your order. That's helic
sleep.com/burr. He likes sleep.com/bar oh Amy. Go. But boop,
boop me on Ds me on d sleeping on a dirty mattress,
but do to to Mandy's beyond the zest cause you got a flat ass.
But when you put me on these around your flat ass,
they cop you fucking balls and you take to get some me undies.
Everybody needs them. Muslims, Christians and Jews. Oh yeah. All right. Mandy's,
whenever you're wearing a suit or sweats,
you spend almost 24 hours a day in your underwear.
But instead of making a statement like Superman's tight under tights,
under his clothes every day,
your underwear is probably boring me undies is here to change that. All right?
Every pair of Mandy's is made by sustainable source modal,
modal of fabric that's twice as soft as cotton.
Nothing can describe the fit and feel of me undies. But once you try them on,
your balls will never go back.
And you'll understand why they're called the world's most comfortable underwear.
And if you don't love your first pair of undies, they're free.
No questions asked. Well, I'm glad you don't take them back.
Like the fucking mattress store meanders has dozens of styles and limited
edition prints to make you make us to help you make a statement with your
underwear where anyone could see them or not. Remember Superman. Alright,
shipping is free in the United States and Canada and you can save up to eight
bucks per pair at me, at me undies with, with the Mandy's subscription plan,
get the subscription or a single pair.
Get 20% off your first order when you go to Mandy's dot com slash bird that's me
on these.com/burr. Hey you undies.com/berg. All right. Lastly,
but certainly not recently is a dollar shave club. Everybody doll,
if I can shave club kid, uh, guys, um,
dollar shave club,
really appreciate you listening to these advertisements on this show and they
wanted to thank you. All right. Um,
what have they done here@dollarshaveclub.com?
They arranged for them to, uh,
what
give new members a month of the executive razor for free just for buying a tube
of Dr Carver's Shave Butter, Aka Dr Covey's easy shape butter.
Um, they're super excited for you to try this. All right.
Now let me remind you why millions of others have joined.
Pres proud members of the club.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing razors right to your front door for a
third of the price of what the greasy, greedy, crazy,
greedy razor corporations charge. That means when you joined dollar Shave Club,
you can afford to shave with a fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic. All right?
Get a first class shave when you use the executive blade.
And that's without hurting your wallet. All right?
And then after you get the executive blade, you use a little doctor cavities,
easy shave butter,
and the blade just gently glides across the smooth surface something or other,
whatever. Shave butter isn't your average shave cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula.
The high quality natural ingredients gradients,
leaves your skin feeling unbelievably soft and smooth is soft as a horse with
muscle now's a great time to join dollar shave club location.
Had No new members who buy a tube of Dr cabbies. Easy shave butter. Get a month
of the executive razor for free. Uh, take advantage of this special offer today.
It's available by going to dollar shave club.com/bar that's dollar shave
club.com/berg all right, that's the podcast for this week. I apologize.
It's a little bit short, but I'm kind of short on time. All right.
If you'd like to donate to this podcast, a great way to do it.
Next time you go onto amazon.com just go to bill bird.com you click on the
podcast page,
click on the Amazon link and it'll take you right to Amazon.
Doesn't cost you any more money.
And they kicked me a couple of bucks for driving traffic. There were a,
once again, as always, have a great week. You fucking cunts.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll talk to you. I'll check in on you on Thursday.